und der Vizekanzler ist uns zugeschaltet
guten Abend
wir sind gerade aus dem Urlaub zurück
wie schön ist das denn wo man im Urlaub
damit quasi aufwacht dass eine
Parteifreunde den nächsten großen
Konflikt in der Koalition vom Zaun
gebrochen hat
das hat mit Urlaub ja nicht zu tun das
ist natürlich jetzt kein Glanzstück
gewesen
andererseits kommt das
Wachstumsbeschleunigungsgesetz jetzt in
der kabinettsäuren mieseberg und auch
bei der Kindergrundsicherung sind wir
auf guten Weg also wenn man mal jetzt
den Streit beiseite lässt kein Schaden
in der Sache wir kriegen das alles gut
hin na ja sie sagen kann Glanzstück das
ist natürlich ähm ich sag meine
Verniedlichung dessen was da eigentlich
passiert ist also in ihrer Abwesenheit
hintergeht quasi eine Parteifreundin sie
und blockiert ein Gesetz dem der Kanzler
der Vizekanzler und der Finanzminister
bereits zugestimmt hat das kann doch
eigentlich nicht sein oder
wie gesagt das Gesetz ist ja jetzt nur
aufgeschoben überhaupt nicht aufgehoben
es ist ein Gesetz dass jetzt nachdem wir
das noch ein bisschen kalibriert haben
gute Impulse setzt ich bin damit ganz
zufrieden es wird auch kommen und es
wird dann den Deutschen Bundestag quasi
in den ersten Sitzungswochen erreichen
also in der Sache ist kein Schaden
entstanden aber ja es ist natürlich
genau das wieder passiert was diese
Regierung bei wie ich finde eigentlich
gute Arbeit in der Sache immer wieder
auszeichnet sich nämlich selber Beine zu
stellen also das ist sehr ärgerlich weil
es immer diesen Eindruck des Streites
hat der ist jetzt da wieder entstanden
aber in der Sache selbst werden mit
diesem diesen diesen Impuls setzen für
die deutsche Wirtschaft dass mir extrem
wichtig es geht ja am Ende um die Sache
naja es ist aber schon symptomatisch
also offenbar gibt es in ihrer Partei
eine ganz erhebliche Wut darüber wie
diese Koalition läuft und der Wunsch an
der Stelle dann irgendwo auch mal mit
der Faust auf den Tisch zu schlagen ohne
Rücksicht auf Verluste und es ist nicht
ganz klar wo jetzt eigentlich das macht
Zentrum bei den Grünen ist also wer bei
ihnen denn eigentlich den Kurs bestimmt
[Applaus]
also die Grünen haben in den letzten
zwei Jahren so viele Entscheidungen
getroffen die nicht in unserem
Wahlprogramm stehen die aber wichtig
waren für das Land und die Stabilität
des Landes das ist er herausragend ist
wie wir uns in die Verantwortung
hineinbegeben haben und ja an der Stelle
hat man nicht geklappt aber da mag
sicherlich auch Frust oder falsche
Taktik eine Rolle gespielt haben aber
insgesamt ist ja doch festzustellen dass
wir in den letzten anderthalb Jahren
sehr viele unangenehme Entscheidungen
selbstbewusst und aus dem Wissen heraus
dass sie notwendig sind getroffen haben
und deswegen würde ich sie nicht
verallgemeinern an der Stelle das
unangenehme ist nur für die
Ampelkoalition das gilt für alle drei
Parteien dass dieser Eindruck dass da
gute Sache Arbeit geleistet wurde bei
der Bevölkerung überhaupt nicht ankommt
also gut man kann auch immer sagen
Umfragen sind Momentaufnahme aber wenn
dann in einem Politbarometer über 80%
sagen diese Koalition kommt überhaupt
nicht voran dann ist das ja ein
wahnsinnig
ja dem stimme ich zu und stimmen
natürlich auch mit der Wirklichkeit
nicht überein wir kommen ja voran wir
haben gerade heute das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht modernisiert
Deutschland wird noch attraktiver für
Menschen die zu uns kommen die
Integrationsleistung wird noch mal
gesteigert einen Schritt würde ich sagen
der lange überfällig war und den in am
Ende nur diese regierungskonstellationen
gehen konnte also wir machen lauter
wichtige Dinge die auch dem Anspruch den
wir selbst gestellt haben nämlich
moderne moderne Regierung zu seinen
fortschrittskoalition zu seinen gerecht
wird aber sie haben völlig recht wir
versauen ist uns permanent selbst und
das ist natürlich auf Dauer kein
Erfolgsgeheimnis warum sagen die
Experten vom Klimarat dass die
Bundesregierung ihre selbst gesteckten
Klimaziele nicht erreichen wird also
dann scheint ja doch nicht so voran zu
gehen wie sie es jetzt darstellen
na die sagen können das gleiche was ich
gesagt habe als ich diesen Bericht
vorgestellt habe wir haben die Lücke die
wir geerbt haben die ich geerbt habe um
80% verkleinert 80 % sind nicht 100% das
stimmt vor allem im Verkehrsbereich
reichen die Maßnahmen nicht das liegt
daran dass wir beim Schmieden dieser
Koalition im Koalitionsvertrag bestimmte
Dinge ausgeschlossen haben von
Tempolimit bis zu Steuererhöhung das
damit werden jetzt irgendwie umgehen
müssen aber das ist jetzt irgendwie auch
keine Überraschung gewesen dass diese
80% nicht 100% sind das habe ich ja
selber gesagt trotzdem
[Musik]
nun sind diese Prognosen die Zukunft
natürlich immer Prognosen deswegen sind
sie quasi aus ihrer Logik heraus nie
hundert Prozent richtig sondern sie
schaffen eine Perspektive die
hoffentlich eintreten wird und es ist
richtig dass bei dem
bei den deutschlandticket die Schätzung
auseinander gehen man weiß ja nicht oder
man lernt jetzt erst wie viele Menschen
ist in Anspruch nehmen und ob dadurch
auch vor allem Verkehre reduziert werden
oder die Menschen mit dem Deutschland
Ticket nur am Wochenende eine Reise mehr
machen da gibt es verschiedene Annahmen
aber es gibt doch ein Korridor oder
Annahme richtig ist dass die Experten
des Verkehrsministeriums und das
klimaschutzministeriums nicht exakt die
gleichen Annahmen machen aber der
Korrektur
also das ist nicht nur so ein bisschen
exakt sondern das ist schon Jens weit
auseinander gehen das ist ja auch nur
ein Symptom dafür dass da eben jeder so
sein Süppchen kocht aber ist noch nicht
mal gemeinsam bezahlen gibt ich
naja ich will aber naja dass ich ein
bisschen anders wir müssen wir haben
eine Lücke bis 2030 von 200 bis 300
Millionen Tonnen sagen wir sage ich
sagte Expertenrat keiner weiß der
Expertenrat nicht und wir nicht ob es
199 Millionen Tonnen sind oder
299 oder irgendwas dazwischen die
entscheidende Botschaft ist ist es eine
Lücke da und diese Lücke muss
geschlossen werden und wir haben im
Moment nicht genug Maßnahmen diese Lücke
zu schließen da sind wir politisch
blockiert in einem gewissen Sinne mehr
Maßnahmen viel mehr Maßnahmen kann es
kaum geben wenn es
radikalermaßnahmen gibt wir haben das
beim Gebäude Energiegesetz also dem
heizungsgesetz gesehen dann schwindet
auch schnell die Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung also müssen wir in der
Umsetzung besser werden wie schnell
werden die Windkraftanlagen gebaut wie
schnell werden Gebäude saniert wie
schnell werden Genehmigungsverfahren für
die dekaronisierung der Industrie
dargestellt das ist der Weg geben
Menschen und auch gehen können und dann
haben wir noch eine Chance die
Klimaschutzziele einzuhalten bzw die
Lücke zu verringern habe ganz zum
Schluss noch zwei oder vier Millionen
Tonnen mehr oder weniger sind ist bei
200 oder 300 ja auch ein bisschen egal
bist entscheidend ist dass wir uns nicht
in den falschen Debatten verlieren
sondern die Maßnahmen jetzt auf die
Straße bringen ah wird ganz zum Schluss
noch eine aktuelle Frage sie bezeichnen
dieses Interview aus das ist auch das
jetzt so nach zehn vor neun vorhin kam
die Meldung vom Flugzeugabsturz bei den
mutmaßlich der wagner-chef pregorian an
Bord war gibt's dazu von Seiten des
Vizekanzler der Bundesregierung schon
eine Stellungnahme
die kann ich noch nicht geben ich
verfolge die Nachrichten wie alle mit
einem gewissen angehaltenen Atem aber
ich habe jetzt keine Erkenntnisse die
ich heute Abend hier in ihrem Journal
darlegen kann also ein bisschen werden
wir uns noch gedulden müssen bis mehr
Klarheit in die Dunkelheit gebracht wird
danke Ihnen